[Music]
whoa that was intense the new Fast and
Furious movie comes out this weekend and
I am pumped as we all know unfortunately
Paul Walker passed away during the
filming of the movie and it left the
filmmakers with a delicate question how
do they finish his scenes while still
respecting his performance I'm Gabe hole
writer and we'll be taking a look at the
various cutting edge techniques they
used to keep walkers character in the
movie and still give them a proper
send-off this is hashtag news Furious 7
is the latest installment of The Fast
and Furious franchise and all the
familiar faces are coming back or once
raw hey that sounded good hey but to
bring back the character of Brian
O'Conner the filmmakers used a variety
of tricks first they brought on Walker's
brothers Cody and Caleb Walker as body
double being Pulse brothers they were
able to capture his mannerisms and
physical performance and then Cody and
Caleb's faces and some shots were later
digitally mapped over using software
from when a digital Peter Jackson's
visual effects firm and his face we're
mapping and something when a digital has
become masters of another technique
director James Wan used had editors
poring through archives of views and
unused footage from previous Fast &
Furious movies the old footage and
sometimes only audio recordings of Paul
Walker were used to reconstruct certain
scenes digitally cutting and pasting the
character into the new film the benefit
of this is that Paul's own real-life
performance is used instead of just
imitating what he might have done now
this might seem a little weird like the
filmmakers are trying to bring a dead
actor back to life but the truth is with
modern effects-heavy movies many action
stars are already having their entire
bodies digitally scanned in order to
pull off some of the trickier visuals
rumor has it that Paul's entire body had
already been fully mapped making the
replication true and exact instead of
just an artist's rendering you might not
know it but this has actually been done
before such as with the deceased Oliver
Reed being digitally inserted into
gladiator even dangerous the commands
wouldn't
and less elegantly with the late Nancy
merchand as Tony Soprano's mother in The
Sopranos out of sight out of mind
so what are the results take a look at
this actual scene from Furious 7 which
used the CGI and body doubling
techniques and see if you can tell if
something's up I think the results look
great so hopefully we can just all enjoy
the movie for what it is and appreciate
this final performance by Paul Walker
the same as if he were still alive
that's it for hashtag news guys if you
like this video please like it below
subscribe whoo look at that text pretty
fancy really subscribe guys we're not
just doing this for our help we're doing
it for you comment with what you think
of a new fast and furious movie I'm Dave
ho writer and if it means I don't have
to come into work anymore you can use
old clips of me anytime
[Music]